i'm sure you've gone to your friend's
house one time and thought who the [ __ ]
did your tv settings it's like the
contrast is [ __ ] ridiculous okay so
whatever my situation is blowing maybe
i'm that guy because i've never thought
that they probably just
they probably just put it on [ __ ]
movie mode and thought that's it that's
for me wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait hold on people put it on
anything but the default settings unless
they have like a home cinema set because
i've never yes yes i've always just put
it on default oh my god i've never
changed my default settings from my
twitter oh the default
[Applause]
some tv's right they like add frames
okay no no okay like that pushes me okay
that's a different story
like all your tvs that wasn't an issue
before smart tvs
that was i noticed that i was i was like
why the [ __ ] does this look off because
we bought like everything was in 24 fps
like this looks too real like it's like
i just don't i don't subscribe to the
notes i'm like this this is gay gamers
have made a mistake more frames don't
always equal better product guys okay
it's like the 60 fps remakes of events
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i get that artificial smoothness
i guarantee you your colors are [ __ ]
on your tv and when you change them
you'll be like i'm an idiot but you
don't know because you just like
watching it yeah but i also don't watch
movies that often yeah right if you're
not watching movies yeah i i i'm not
even talking i'm not even talking about
movies i'm talking about any form of
media really because like i remember
your games your game call is probably
wrong
like your pc monitor i don't know
you don't you don't care until you know
and then you're like god damn it like
this game was more beautiful because
like you can get these devices that uh
point at the screen yeah
ghost of tsushima looked beautiful on my
default setting tv
oh no
you can get these devices on your pc
right because
when you're editing thumbnails yeah
don't you want to know that the
thumbnail that you're editing is like
the right color because you might be
editing it on your monitor which is
wrong colors and you're sending this
thumbnail out and has different colors
yeah but i'm okay because i guarantee
the majority of other people who look at
that are probably also looking at it
through their defaults so the idea is
that if you have your monitor on like uh
the like the most default kind of the
the flattest color profile um that you
know when it gets to an iphone when they
change the brightness it goes to samsung
they change the brightness that like you
don't you're not like doubly skewing the
the messed upness to it if that makes
sense right you don't want it to be
[ __ ] on both ends you want to be the
correct thing on your end so when it
goes to someone else's device that's
that's wrong that it doesn't look
completely messed up right um because i
noticed that uh i used to used to have
like one or two my thumbnails really
weird on some of my friends tv and i was
like huh and it was because my colors on
my monitor were like it was the
manufacturer's default which is awful
awful like i had an msi monitor i don't
know how they messed up the colors on
this monitor so much it was so bad right
so so bad and it was just like i don't
know how to
what's the right color i don't [ __ ]
know so you just buy this device point
it at the screen tells you what to do
i'm a be real dog i've never done that
i i've never once noticed but it's like
having it's like having a
[ __ ] pair of pants or something like you
just don't know it's [ __ ] until you get
a good pair right a lot of the time i
don't know just like you don't know it's
bad
to me to me my life you don't know
you're cycling on a ship bike until
someone points it out in the comments
that's just how it is it's like it's
like yeah it'll do the job
maybe you want to kind of get it better
i mean i i hope i can see color just
fine i i think i can i've never i don't
know that's red right that's purple
that's why we have like this set to like
you know a certain color profile so that
it looks the same on every this device
this is why i'm not a cinematographer or
like i hate working with like cameras
because i just like my brain just like
doesn't process it it's the same with
filming right we filming this thing so
that when it goes to everyone's [ __ ]
up tvs that hopefully because we filmed
it correctly it doesn't look as [ __ ]
up on their tv right right no because
what okay because you'll notice on some
screenshots
from people take picture their tvs
sometimes trash tastes looks way lighter
sometimes they look way darker
i've never noticed
i'm not gonna lie dog
dead ass it's little things never
noticed
i don't look at the details in my brain
i'm like are we recording yes or no
if it's yes good if it's no bad this is
like the opposite of beeps and boops you
know yeah it really is
it belongs on the big screen and i can't
believe that it took your name and acura
for you to watch them even go ah yes big
screen good i don't know because like
there's there are still like
you're telling me this you're telling me
james [ __ ] cameron's avatar like was
dog [ __ ] on a tv that movie was only
watchable on a cinema like experience
also it was pretty it was amazing it was
a movie it was
even a movie like that that was like mid
there's so so much better cinema because
here's here's the thing right here's the
thing yeah i'm not i'm trying to find a
way to describe this because you know
watching let's say og interviews of like
steven spielberg and you know hearing
some directors talk about the art of
filmmaking and you know cinema and
everything they'd always talk about the
magic of cinema this is this feeling
i'm just like i'm like i'm like growing
up i'm like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about magic of cinema bro
people who don't go to the cinema this
is just a marketing point
i'm like i'm like you're just trying to
sell tickets just tell me you're trying
to sell it
because you're trying to tell me
yourself it's got too expensive yes
going to the cinema is
expensive yeah it's like you know who
the [ __ ] wants to pay to go to all this
[ __ ] all the time like yeah i could just
watch it at home for free
what i'm saying is watching your name
i'm just like oh i get it that's the
magic of cinema yeah i get it now
because like i remember when your name
came out everyone was just like oh
silent voice is better slime voice is
better and i'm just like well and you
know technically i think sun voice has
is has a better plot and no better
written characters but if you're gonna
tell me which film i'd rather watch
in cinemas well silent voice is
basically an extended tv program versus
your name which is i think
a story that was made to be displayed in
theaters yes whereas silent voice i
think you you know the enjoyment
obviously will be increasing theaters
but i don't think you're losing too much
by watching it on your tv or something
like you know that's that's kind of what
i mean that's kind of what i'm saying
where there are some films that make you
feel this magic of cinema and i thought
it was just marketing [ __ ] there's a
lot of films where you feel like
yes this had to be experienced this way
yeah and like us ever since then there's
been like a few more films like
especially like seeing
the avengers in cinemas as well that was
that was something that i think
lost
loses his edge not being experienced
with everyone else at the same time in
cinema sorry joey you know you've missed
the bojo you've missed the boat yeah
not that i was going to catch that boat
anyway
i don't know i think maybe it's just
because i i you know i go to the cinema
a lot and i enjoy it and i i really
i treasure that experience a lot it
means a lot to me see but like that's
the thing it's like for you that's
cinemas for me that's live shows yeah
right it's like same same same idea just
different executions because to me what
it sounds it's like you're to me it's
like the same way i've been as being
like just listen to the album why do you
got to go and see them live yeah exactly
like it's like it's like i would never
uh like it's it's like of course 99 of
music
sounds way better in the live setting
yeah exactly yeah i must say like
auto-tune to [ __ ] and then yeah yeah but
i don't listen to that
thing
the majority of music or media is
there's a there's a yes it's the best
way that you can enjoy why why is why is
things enhanced by it being live you
know whether it be like [ __ ] twitch
or like live shows as well
it's just it's the communal communal
aspect feels like you're in on it that's
because
you know you you hear about people talk
about live shows and you know you know
something you say is like oh you had to
be there you had to be there yeah yeah
and it sounds cheesy but like you've
like
when i go to live shows i find it so
hard to verbalize the feeling and the
experience i felt
within that live show versus
experiencing that same piece of media
that same music that same show on a cd
or like or or something else
what sets it apart i mean i def i mean
when it comes to music stuff like i feel
definitely some genres just work better
in a cd setting obviously compared to a
live show or like they're not all that
much
well yeah i mean like i guarantee like a
lot of ambient music is probably going
to sound and feel the exact [ __ ] same
right live or not but like i think i
think when like musicianship is involved
with like multiple people or even like
one person and just like the energy you
feel in that room that you're like oh
i'm experiencing this with everyone else
yeah i can see the magic being created
on stage like in person you know it's
the difference between like
i don't know uh [ __ ] seeing a
painting on a wall versus actually
watching the artist paint that same
painting right like you'd much rather
see the process being done rather than
just experiencing the result yeah
because i every live show i've been to
i'm sure you can agree with this as well
it's like yeah it's it's been way better
live seeing it live oh yeah especially
like musicians and stuff like that
especially if they're good musicians
like yeah a hundred percent maybe it's
maybe something like part of the brain
that's like mob mentality right where
it's like you just you feed off the
crowd and being a part of it yeah
definitely being in that energy you feel
like you're
oh my god i can feed off everyone else
getting hyped and i feel like it all
builds yeah we're weird creatures yeah
i don't think lions get hyped about
other lions you know what i mean i don't
think they get like oh no man they seem
to hype each other up
without hunting the [ __ ] dude i mean
they hunted but i don't know if they're
getting like they're feeding off each
other bro when they when they spot that
elk in the distance
i think it's like a quirk of our
evolution yeah into the idea of being a
part of something big well yeah it's the
difference between you know a caveman
dancing around a fire on his own versus
a caveman dancing around the fire with
other cavemen yeah it's like i if i miss
a game a league of legends whatever game
or a football game which i don't watch
um yeah you know i i'm never going to go
back and watch the vod i don't know i
don't know i'm like i want to i want to
feel you want to be there be there live
yeah know that everyone's losing their
collective [ __ ] when something crazy
happens right that's part of the fun
that's why like yeah like as much as i
love the live show experience and
watching musicians do stuff live that's
why i very rarely unless it's like my
favorite band i very rarely watch like
live dvds or like live footage i hate
listening to live concerts and cds i i
just yeah it depends how they've
recorded obviously if it's on a [ __ ]
iphone then it's gonna sound like dog
[ __ ] yeah yeah but like some some
professionally recorded like live albums
and stuff like that they can sound
really good but it's like
i'm only listening to that because
that's the best that i have because i
wasn't there when it was actually yeah
i don't know but if i was there when it
was recorded i'm not going to
listen to it i actually think live
recordings okay okay here's
you've just unlocked like a memory i
guess where if i have the choice to
download a studio recorded song or a
live recorded song where i can hear the
audience reaction i always go for the
live recording really yeah because i'm
just like damn it just
makes the music sound better and i don't
know why i agree it's like a different
energy yeah yeah yeah i just like the
idea that it's kind of like an art piece
where it's like you have designed the
perfect
thing that you think this is not yeah
can you perform it every perfect every
time or whatever yeah but maybe the
roughness of performing it live adds
more character too yeah i think it does
hearing you know not sometimes you you
hear like an offbeat note or like
there's something
slightly off tune or something like that
you know like maybe a voice
i feel like that adds to the music to me
and hearing the perfect studio version
isn't always like the best experience
for me yeah yeah i've never thought
about that yeah when when i tried it
like all my spotify playlists i tried to
put as many live performances oh really
as i can put
none i hate them
i think as long as like maybe with some
exceptions like some live albums that
are like exceptionally well recorded
other than that i don't normally listen
to live versions because it's like i
would rather listen to this
actually in person like i don't want to
live vicariously through a crowd i'm
listening through spotify no no no
it's not like it's not that i don't want
to be there of course i want to be there
but like if i if i if i have a choice if
i could cope i'd be like
if i close my eyes i could pretend i'm
there okay i can pretend i'm there i say
this knowing that like deaf punk had
that live album which was sick yeah yeah
[ __ ] but that's because that was so well
recorded that was right and it was also
completely different to anything else
yeah
that was crazy but if it's the same song
as the studio version i'd rather listen
to the studio if i can have around the
world without people chewing in the
background i'll just take that one yeah
but the matter
makes the song so much more the mashup
version is sick though yeah look at that
yeah because it's different yeah yeah
the def punk live album was okay that's
an exception
that's just mashups it wasn't the same
song yeah because if the contents the
only time i would uh i would listen to a
live album is if the contents is
something that i can't get off any
studio mm-hmm then then it's like then
that's just like new music yeah right
and so i was like hell yeah i just
and then the hype kind of builds into it
right because it was built off of that
but if it's the exact same song i'd
rather just go to their concert see to
me the crowd
just by having a crowd there you're
adding like an extra light we should
have a crowd trash taste episode that
would be it
trash takes is filmed in front of a live
studio audience
shout out to our live tour by the way
let's see what the tour is going to be
come see we need to start the tour we
need to start every tour with just some
time this time yeah but like but like if
we do another tour just every time we
just got to start it off with this this
show is performed in front of a live
audience
i'll do that i'll be the guy i'll just
do it introduce slap bass